author and columnist mark Stein joins us
right now last in nobodies column mark
what's going on with the Biden campaign
I know it was a small poll and it's just
one Paul when we 320 people in it but my
goodness
he's lost double digits in points on
that very same poll in a short time
what's going on yeah and it's only two
months ago that the hill which reported
on this poll new poll was saying that he
would wallop Trump in a landslide
head-to-head there's not gonna be a
Biden Trump head-to-head he's not going
to be by the time we get to the Iowa
caucus and the New Hampshire primary or
the Vermont primary as he'd say he's not
going to be in the race I love old
people I'm the least ages person in the
media and when I listen to people say
well Biden made these gaffes when he was
65 55 25 he made these gaffes in middle
school the point is when he was doing
that they're gonna put y'all back in
Chains stuff he still had vigor there
are people with a decade and a half on
his age who have more vigor Janice Steen
talked to one a knowledge anarion on
your show this morning who had more
energy than Joe Biden he's not gonna
stick around for Iowa and New Hampshire
he'll be gone before then he's got over
50 a wide swath a large chunk of the
african-american vote among Democrats
but the first two primaries don't have a
great black vote in New Hampshire and
Iowa ones the caucus wins a primary will
even get to South Carolina if he doesn't
win either one of those is that your
point yeah no I don't I think at some
point he he's in the position that a lot
of early frontrunners are he's electable
because he's electable the minute you
have more polls showing him in third
place the principled rationale for his
candidacy evaporates what it is what is
his message what is his platform
what is his slogan what is his theme the
the only thing is going for him is that
he's been around forever years name
recognition and is therefore presumed to
be elected electable when you have polls
showing him in third place
and worse if he starts slipping into
fourth place between Bello people no one
had ever heard of three months ago then
the entire rationale for the Biden
campaign disappears I ask you to do a
lot of things mark in the past whether
it's on the Fox and Friends couch or on
this very set not when asked you do
play-by-play on better O'Rourke he has
decided to fry a burger on camera
because the dentist thing didn't really
pan out for him can you try to explain
to make heads or tails of this he
decides to tell us he fries burgers how
does that well yes
well because baitoey wok has been doing
this thing where he had his ear hair
trimmed live on camera then he went to
the dentist live on camera and people
thought well he's just some shallow
narcissist with no substance so he's
decided to show us he has got substance
and following his success at at changing
a tire without actually jacking the car
up
he's now decided to fry a burger it's a
very bizarre situation he's got going
there with that burger that seems to be
some kind of English muffin he's he's
either putting the bag on I don't know
about that I don't want that kind of
thing
I would not and I don't know about two
clumps of broccoli next to the burger
but if this is what the new menu is
going to be in the in the baito White
House it's not something you want to get
mixed up with I think the American
public is rejecting the minutiae
albedo's life meanwhile on another thing
senator Kirsten Gillibrand has been in
this race forever and she's changed her
views on everything from immigration to
what she thinks of the Clintons who were
an ally for years and mentored her to
that spot that Senator Hillary Clinton
would actually give up to become
Secretary of State and now our campaign
seems to wreak rumbling allies want her
to drop out and she's still very
confident though in her moral
superiority of everybody else this
country was founded on some basic moral
principles that we have a moral compass
as a nation our morality as a country is
literally on a knife's edge for me it's
really a moral question for me it's very
much a moral question I've been called
to fight as hard as I
Sibley can to restore that moral
integrity that moral decency well
there's the moral integrity and decency
going to propel her do you think no I
think her bobble compass is actually
sitting at the bottom of Lake Champlain
she represented a district in upstate
New York hard by the Quebec border and
she had very moderate very centrist
views that she's tossed overboard along
with her twirling moral compass in the
last three months so she just comes
across as a shallow opportunist without
the excuse of Joe Biden that she barely
remembers what country she's in so so
she has a city is she is not the same
person she was five years ago and that
gives her a credibility issue it makes
her sound fake when she's lecturing
audiences in Youngstown Ohio on how
they're suffering from white privilege
this is this is someone who just and
embodies all the worst most opportunists
most shallow aspects of politics
whatever you want to say about Elizabeth
Warren or Bernie Sanders or President
Trump they are themselves they stay with
their same issues they barely bend they
do some nuances so people can have a
real sense of who they're not voting for
or voting for